dressed in a pair of blue dungarees in
the arms of mother Kate Prince George's
life of public engagements begins a play
date with 10 other under ones and their
parents a chance for both mum and dad
and Prince George to make friends George
may have put a smile on most faces since
arriving in New Zealand but this little
girl was less than impressed with
George's advances an apologetic hand
from Kate failed to stem the tears onto
the next little girl in the room and an
issue with ownership George had his eye
on a toy his strength unquestionable his
handling skills need a little more work
finally with a toy of his own it was
straight into the mouth for this
teething tot then George was unleashed
on all fours for his first public
walkabout or rather for dad meanwhile
seemed happy to chat and leave Kate to
get down with the kids Prince George's
first playdate his first public
engagement his first crawl about
whatever you want to call it it's all
going on here behind the gates of
Government House just a handful of
cameras and one or two newspaper
journalists only are allowed inside to
record this moment just how significant
these pictures are could be measured by
the number of times
similar footage has been used over
recent years of another young prince on
the lawn of Government House in 1983
this time in Auckland Prince William was
introduced to the world unfazed by his
first photo call the teething nine month
old New Zealand's future king endeared
himself to the country for ever having
taken a liking to the now famous buzzy
bee thirty-one years later a proud
father will no doubt hope New Zealand
warms to his son in equal measure it
seems like he's off to a good start